is your dad happy now with your career
choice man you've you've your big
success you know you're in the number
one movie in the country very funny on
Silicon Valley one of the funniest shows
on television you got a he's got to give
it up for you now right well he's still
wish like I was a scientist or something
I thought right actually he started
acting after I did I became like the
Angelina Jolie of the family because he
was like oh oh a back things so easy you
can do it I can probably do it right and
I was like you know what if I'm gonna
teach you a lesson so you can see how
hard the audition process is so so I
asked my agent if like she could sign
him up at the time and she was like yeah
of course like apparently there's a lack
of old Asian people in the Hollywood
business they're a rare commodity didn't
know that so they signed them up and
then my dad booked like first the first
four out is four six auditions oh my god
which is unheard of so playing
completely backfired
oh yeah this is easy this is awesome no
what are you doing wow this is super
easy yeah yeah hey come play back for I
like my aunt from Shanghai will call the
house be like Richard you're so good
your son must have taken after you you
should get in this strip club business
now yeah that's next any questioning all
right let's take it easy okay look
you